let's get the latest military analysis
of the situation in ukraine with the
defense and security analyst professor
michael clark
thanks um we know that the russians have
left kharkiv
they've they've been pushed out
effectively right up to the the border
between ukraine and russia this is a
withdrawal not so much a a big defeat
but because they've decided to relocate
their troops to bring them round to this
offensive that's going on much further
south the important thing to remember
about this offensive is it's really
defined by the river the donier river
which runs down the map as you can see
here too severe donetsk and further down
and by and large generally the russians
are to the east of the river the
ukrainians are to the west of the river
both of them have got quite good
defensive positions either side of that
river but of course if you're attacking
as the russians are trying to do then
that river becomes a problem so let's
just look at what the russians have
tried to do in the bigger map of the
area
essentially if we think about this the
donbass region this offensive began as
something rather grand running
effectively from kharkiv the second city
to mariopol that was what the russians
were originally trying it seems to
achieve far too much
they then seem to concentrate much more
on running from isiam to donetsk that's
what we thought they were doing really
up until last week
the last 24-36 hours seems to indicate
that they're bringing these troops from
kharkiv and some other troops that
they've had in belgorod not committed to
kharkiv that they're bringing them
around to a much smaller but more
intensive offensive from sevier donetsk
to svitladask
and in a sense what they're trying to do
is to bite a very small chunk of the
donbass with intensive numbers of troops
but they haven't yet taken uh severe
donetsk they've got it on three sides
they tried to cross the river to
encircle it that was a complete fiasco
they've still got to go to get across
the donets river in order to make any
real headway
final talking point really is mario poll
of course made apollo is always the
talking point
the azov style steel works and the
apparent use of white phosphorus and
incendiaries
at mario paul difficult issue um
they're not they're not illegal in
battle they can be used as a an
illuminant and as a smoke uh creator
however if they're used directly if
they're used directly against personnel
or in any civilian areas of course that
is illegal lots of examples of them
around the world this is by now is the
first time the reason that white
phosphorus gets used is because in these
sort of situations it works